[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__]
ah the smell of freedom of speech this
is the Tony Michaels podcast and this is
Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them I love the smell of Republican rap
stepping in the
morning welcome to the Tony Michaels
podcast it is January 10th
today is designed not to
disappoint because we will be talking
about Hunter Biden's dick today that's
right because
Republicans continue to step on the
hunter Biden rake and it's all because
they need to distract from their
musolini Jesus their mango musolini
Jesus Grant paaul Hitler's
Troubles of becoming the dictator of the
United States of America running for
dictator of the United States of America
I might add and this is the entire
reason why we are here in this moment
today the [__] committee yes as the
Discord chat says the [__]
committee this morning uh Hunter Biden
goes balls
deep into Republican
nonsense shows up on the hill as okay
get
this the house oversight committee that
is that is chaired by comr pile is
holding a contempt hearing and so is Jim
Jordan's Judiciary Committee neither one
of them are going very
swimmingly but let me tell you moscowitz
is in the oversight committee AOC
Goldman ratkin and Jasmine Crockett
might I I'm gonna be perfectly honest
with you here she is my favorite
Congress person of all time of all time
of all
time she I just I can't get over
it the language that she
uses the hammer that she that she wields
and uses holy actual [__] I cannot wait
to show you these clips right now the
the traitor Paul goar is speaking it's
funny because they're they're voting
on Hunter Biden listen to this they're
voting on Hunter Biden if you don't know
the news yet they're voting on Hunter
Biden today for criminal contempt
referral okay because he defied a
subpoena to come in and talk to the
committee even though he was there in
the room today in the same room is three
other
[__]
Republicans three other
[__] who absolutely will not
comply with the subpoena with the
January 6 select committee lawful
subpoena by the way decided by the
courts that it's lawful if you want to
respect the rule of law and respect
courts we respect that [__]
huh
Republicans look ridiculous and the
reason why is because they are
ridiculous but the only reason why this
this is going on today is because they
already have a dictator they already
have a
furer they already have a king they have
already seated their entire party to the
to the theoretical Theocratic monarchy
of
trump this is not because comr pile
wants to do this this is not because the
members of the oversight committee want
to look like
fools Donald Trump owns rake factories
and he is making sure that Republicans
step on every last [__] one of them
now he's doing it to protect his own ass
I don't know what he thinks he's
accomplishing I have no idea this this m
this makes no sense at all really all
they did this morning was undermine
their entire message by having Hunter
Biden show up live in person saying I'm
ready to [__] answer questions when
they're voting on him to to to
criminally refer him for contempt of
congress for not complying with the
subpoena when he's in the [__] room
he was physically in the [__] room
ready to answer questions in front of
the American people wouldn't do it
there's a reason why they won't do
it because they don't have the ability
to not look like dumb
[__] and completely make their message
burn to ashes and let the Democrats
including Jasmine Crockett piss all over
it and that's the point that's what I
keep the point I keep trying to make
over and over every [__] day is that
narrative is the only thing that matters
I I know you're like no Tony law and
this and that yeah but listen if you let
these [__] fascists take over our
governments you're not going to have the
[__] Constitution you're not going to
have the [__] we have to win
[__] we have to
win that should be the number one
[__] goal because their their goal is
not to legislate I don't know if you
noticed that they don't give a [__]
about the American people they're going
to shut down the government I've been
I've been telling you that and telling
you that and you
know but the March 4th date 14th
Amendment and I keep telling you these
things because I don't know it it
doesn't matter to me what feels good I
don't give a [__] what feels
good it doesn't feel good to have our
House of Representatives that is held
with a majority by two [__]
votes doing nothing for the American
people and hellbent on doing nothing for
the American people [__] they're saying
it out loud Troy nles of Texas says
there's no way he's gonna support our
vote on any kind of Bill that would help
Joe Biden look good even if it helps the
American people he don't give a [__]
Donald Trump said just the other day he
hopes the economy crashes so it makes
him look
good because it makes Joe Biden look bad
he wants your suffering they want your
suffering so that they can Crown Donald
Trump king of America and have their
Theocratic
monarchy and assert their Rule and the
their power on you and tell you what the
[__] you're gonna do and what the [__]
you ain't gonna do and if you don't
comply they will kill you even if even
if King Trump has to get sealed Team Six
to do it because everyone knows that he
can't be criminally prosecuted for that
crime oh yeah Tony always wraps it up in
a little
bow no one else will [__] do it why
not me no one no one is gonna tell you
what I just told you how I told you that
[__] no
one Jasmine Crockett got really [__]
really [__] close today
though I'm GNA I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say I'm always like no no because people
like Tony you should run for Congress or
whatever you should run for office and
I'm like no no no they don't they don't
want someone saying the [__] I say in
the [__] house chamber in the house
committee and then I look at Jasmine
Crockett I'm like holy
[__] God damn
I mean she she is 100% my spirit animal
oh
[__] holy
moly that is how it is done and I'm
gonna show you that clip I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you the clip now I wish I
wish I had um more great stuff to talk
about this morning but this this is so
[__] delicious and so [__] good
and the reason why is because at one
point at one one
point Congressman bigs takes the bait on
The subpoena that he that he hasn't
complied with Scott Perry takes the bait
on the on the subpoena that he hasn't
complied with and they start arguing the
merits of why they why they broke the
law why why they're above the law and
the law doesn't count for them and they
got a immunity sounds [__] familiar
doesn't it again the reason why we're
here isn't because the
Republicans the politicians and the ones
controlling the party are really [__]
dumb it's be it's because the disease is
dumb the disease is dumb it's white
Christian nationalism folks it's the
reason why we're
here this is why we are here in the
first place in this stupid the dumbest
[__] timeline in American
history
it's because of white Christian
nationalism I'm going to show you
another video today of another Trump
supporter telling you what I've been
telling you the reason why Donald
Trump's gonna be the [__]
nominee oh man I've heard it this
morning oh oh [__] Nikki Haley she's
gonna be president of the United States
according to the media and according to
the
polls polls I man the polls I mean the
media is trying to sell you anything
they can tell you that Donald Trump's
not going to be the nominee like
anything they can [__]
do anything they can [__]
do to try to sell you that no no no it's
okay it's okay don't freak out he won't
be the
nominee even though he's gonna be the my
nominee and I understand their their
logic in it their logic is is
that they believe they
believe that they control the narrative
still that they drive the national
narrative they believe that they can
they can make people believe things if
they just say
them and the media's right in that it
used to work that way a lot they did
have the narrative there was only a
couple stations that people could listen
to only a couple pieces of news that
people could actually digest each day
not in the world we live in in
2024 for those on Twitch who want to
challenge that I know what year it is
not in the year
2024 now they do not have that power
anymore they do not they do not possess
the ability to control the
narrative across America he just don't
there's the [__] internet thing you
know that internet machine thingy that
thing you know what I'm talking
about and it's People Like Us that
control the narrative social media exist
and it's the people like the
Liars the misinformer the Republicans
the right-wing Talking Heads that
control the narrative why do you think
why do you think so many people believe
in this country that Donald Trump is the
best thing since sliced bread and he's
chosen by God huh do you think do you
think they just came up with that [__]
on their
own do you think that the n910 I think
it's getting lower I used to say 12 13%
of the country uh is in the cult you
know what I mean like the Diehard cult
is the one that believe crazy ass [__]
like they're lost you ain't going to
convince them but I think it's getting
smaller and
smaller it's getting smaller and smaller
the cult is getting smaller and smaller
but the affiliation has
grown right the affiliation has
grown I I don't know if you've listened
to any of these white Christian
nationalists these these these [__]
right-wing preachers and [__] lately but
they're they're not they're not backing
the
Santas they're hell hella sure not going
to be backing Nikki Haley
you you think these toxic misogynist
[__] Evangelical ministers ministers
Chris White Christian naist are gonna
are gonna [__]
back a brown woman in their party to be
their Nom you're [__] out of your
mind you are out of your [__] mind
you are not paying attention and you
haven't been paying attention at all
whatsoever yeah but Tony there's a
process and and and and look in New
Hampshire Nikki Haley is catching up to
Trump and oh and by the way in New
Hampshire is is an Open Primary so
there's no Democratic uh uh what what
primary so and and but Nikki Haley I
hope she wins that's what I want I hope
she wins I hope Nikki Haley wins you
hope you hope you hope
[__] I hope I'm 6 foot eight tomorrow
that ain't going to happen I can want in
one hand and [__] in the other and see
which one fills up first this is so
ridiculous the entire reason why this
morning the H every single house
Republican is going to make fools of
themselves is to make Donald Trump the
nominee don't you understand don't you
get it
the entirety of the Republican party
that is now elected to the House of
Representatives this morning is making
absolute [__] fools of themselves in
front of the American people when
they're saying we're gonna vote to
criminally
refer Hunter Biden because he won't show
up and answer questions and he was in
the [__] room they acknowledged his
existence and his presence
and you think the American people are
going to buy that
[__] I mean the cult will right anyone
who's completely convinced of anything
that that the Facebook says to them you
know what I mean you know you know what
I mean I mean it could be the Twitter
too now the [__] xchan Jesus Christ
good Lord what a [__] hell hole
Twitter has
become I mean I kind of like it as a
hell hole better I'm not going to lie I
like it better as a hell
hole I mean everyone's like this wasn't
the original intent of Twitter and I'm
like well then you don't know how
Americans work Americans always always
always always in
Forever take the thing that they're
using and use it for stuff that was not
the intent like that's the American
[__]
way you know what I mean that's how
that's how that's how emergency room
stay in [__] business in this
country that's not its original intent
Timmy well I'm American goddamn
it and as an American it is my right to
stick this where it's not supposed to
be come on man I'm I mean you know
there's going to be a lot of
phallic references uh to today on the
show because Marjorie Taylor green even
tried to enter in pictures of Hunter
Biden's
dick or his huge hog as it
were it is the hunter hog show this
morning this is not the Tony Michaels
podcast it is the hunter hog show and
yes yes yes we're gonna talk about
Hunter Biden's dick I'm sure it's going
to come
up and yes I'm probably going to show
you a little bit of footage from this
Byron Donald I'm watching it right now
live uh Byron Donald's is actually
speaking or if that's what you call it
uh puking puking up propaganda out of
his mouth and lies that's all Byron
Donalds decides to do do you remember
Byron Donald's you remember this guy he
was he was their he was their black
nominee for speaker of the house when
Democrats pointed out that AEM Jeff was
the black nominee for speaker of the
house they're like oh we got we got us
black dude too yeah bring up my African
Amer we got a black friend they did the
whole we got a black friend too and then
Byron Donald's got some attention right
and I don't know if it's because his
last name is like the F her's first name
I'm not really sure what happened but he
went on a media tour um a live Fest
puking up [__] just absolute
[__] on the media this Byron
Donald's character
and we find out he's a
criminal yeah he's a fraudster I guess
he he got felony charges for credit card
fraud or stealing credit some [__] some
[__] I don't know I don't know it's not
surprising that a Republican and
Congress is a thief right I mean that
wouldn't be that big of a surprise would
it I mean this morning this morning they
can't they can't even handle uh certain
procedures Margery Taylor green at one
points tries to tries to make a point of
order
oh my God and Daniel Goldman because
Daniel Goldman's sitting in the room uh
in the oversight Committee hearing and
Daniel Goldman and and for people who
don't know Daniel Goldman is an attorney
and he's a really good attorney but the
thing that he's really good at is
because he's been on the hill for so
long he he like knows procedure in a
congressional hearing he he knows what
rules are in a congressional hearing and
he always points out that Republicans
like Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren
Bower are dumb [__] and they have no
idea what the rules are and how
committee hearings work um and he does
so eloquently this morning in the [__]
committee along with Jamie Rasin
absolutely torching every single one of
these fools AOC doing a magnificent job
as well but Jasmine Crockett is the
Highlight I promise you she is the
[__] highlight of this of this of the
clips that I'm going to show you today
there is no better messaging would say I
would put because you know I'm always
I'm I'm always pimping Hakeem Jeff on
his messaging right oh man I cannot wait
until hakee Jeff is the speaker of the
house I believe if it's up to us in the
Pro democracy Coalition and we get our
[__] together and stop listening to
[__] idiots in the media who are
grifting you just trying to get you to
watch just to say [__] that you like and
you want to hear changing their position
changing changing what they say all the
time walking [__] back going this way
going that way trying to [__] that [__]
pick a position and stick to it pick a
[__] commentary and stick to it would
you
please and more than likely what you
should really [__] do is you should
watch this show and then you'll just
know what it's supposed to be going
forward yes I'm gonna say it I'm that
confident in the messaging of this show
I'm that confident in the message that
will carry the majority in the house for
many years to come under Hakeem Jeff and
if you doubt me you can go listen to
Hakeem Jeff the way that he messaged and
and the narratives that he puts
forward and you understand exactly how
it
works we cannot sit back and fight nice
with these [__] fascists who want to
make Donald Trump the dictator and the
king of the United States and undermine
our constitution our democracy and strip
away our freedoms and rights they did it
to women by by by taking away roie Wade
and now they're trying to ban and
criminalize pregnancies in these Nazi
House of Representatives in these states
and ban their [__] privacy and
doctors office take away parental
consent away from parents who have trans
and lgbtq children they wantan to they
want to make sure that you cannot you
cannot be anything they don't want you
to be out in [__] public
[__] that
[__] I don't believe that the American
people are going to put up with that
bull [__] and especially when white
Christian nationalists say that they
want a Theocratic monarchy and they want
dict taster to taste dick for one day
that's all they want just one day and
maybe he'll just order SEAL Team Six to
kill any of his enemies because he's
immune from murder charges if he gets
seal te six to do it
[__] that
[__] and anyone else not saying it that
way or seeing it that way isn't seeing
it through the correct lens and again
the threat here is not that fat [__]
down at Mar Lago their cult leader is
weak and feeble [__] he can barely hold
his butt cheeks together to keep a his
ass from leaking into his diaper okay we
should not be scared of trump and we
definitely 100% should not be scared of
[__] MAA or these white Christian
nationalists we [__] outnumber
them it is fundamentally
100% unequivocally unamerican to support
Donald Trump or Maga period they have
proven it every [__] time and it
never will stop and it never will end
until we finally throw the last shovel
of dirt onto the Republican party in
this
country [__] them that party's been dead
for a long goddamn time and I'm tired
and the American people are tired of
dragging around the dead body that the
Republican Party their corpse of a party
that they are because you will never as
long as I'm around and long as this
microphone's on and as long as this
audience Powers this microphone I will
never ever stop pointing out that you
cannot wash the Nazi off the Republican
party
ever not in my country not in our
country you don't get to do that
[__] and and and think that you can just
tuck tail and run and oh you well we'll
wipe the stench off I'm looking at you
Paul Ryan Liz jany and Chris Christie
and Mitt Romney and the like
Adam kininger I'm looking at you
[__] you don't get to wipe the
stench
off once a Nazi always a [__] Nazi
they should be branded that way from now
until the end of time if you don't want
to be a Nazi start another party
otherwise you're just you're just
carrying around the dead corpse of the
gqp and this morning it's on display in
the oversight committeee that they not
only do they not know how to [__]
govern one because they're doing nothing
for the American people American people
don't want this
[__] they want you to keep
government open they want you to fund
their [__] roads and their Bridges
they want to make sure you're doing
something so they don't go broke because
of a [__] medical bill they want to
make sure you do something so we get a
decent [__] wage so we ain't got to
worry about corporate Fat Cats stealing
all our [__] GDP you
[__] we want to make sure that
you educate our [__] children with
the money we give you we want to make
sure you protect earned benefits like
Social Security Medicare you sons of
[__] [__] not talking about Hunter
Biden's dick and showing pictures off
some [__] some [__] lamptop that
you think is
real are talking about some [__]
truck payment that Joe Biden helped
Hunter bide make you stupid
[__] Americans don't give a
[__] about Hunter Biden they don't give
a
[__] it's only the [__] loud ones
that you hear and that's why I got to be
loud every [__]
weekday we gotta Get Loud [__]
we gotta Get Loud because they yell and
scream and it feels like it feels like
there's so many of them and there's not
we don't need to be afraid of that [__]
we need to go at them lean into it [__]
them and [__] their lies it's time it's
time it's time to [__] take this
country into a place that we can get
back to [__] the Americans people's
business and the only party that's
[__] interested in doing that is the
one who even gives a glimpse of
believing in democracy and that ain't no
[__]
Republican they've sold their entire
soul in their entire party to a dictator
to a King to a Theocratic monarchy
because they love white Christian
nationalism and they've bought into it
hook line Sinker and the delusion and
that disease of white Christian
nationalism is metastasizing in their
party good for
you we are not going to provide the
treatment for your disease you can go
[__] yourself and you can come here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Cent 9 Pacific on
YouTube the books of face twitch and
Instagram don't go anywhere I'm going to
show you these clips [__] clay
Higgins that [__] weirdo is talking
right now maybe when we come back we'll
watch him don't go anywhere don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast
are you ready for best pizza of Life
bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hugs spot
Pizza your tummy say thank you your
mouth say m pepperoni hug spot it's like
family but with more cheese
catch Tony's twitch stream the [__] list
Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michaels we're back to
the king of Brilliance this is the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast it's grifting time are you ready
to
grift ch- ching ching banging you know
what I
[Music]
mean I mean how You' expect me to keep
the power on and the lights on you know
I don't have any good boner pills to
sell you today I don't have any good
boner pills or some kind of supplement
that'll make your your your wiener as
big as Hunter Biden's hog or that make
you feel healthy and active and
energetic I mean if you want that just
listen to the front first 30 minute rant
that'll get you all [__] pumped up
and fired up any more than any kind of
scam ass supplement
will maybe one day maybe one day we'll
Hawk Hunter Biden boner bills I'm just
saying it's a possibility right I'm sure
I'm sure there's a hunter buy boner pill
company out there would love for me to
talk to you about their [__] their
boner supplements just saying or they're
you some kind of powder you put in water
and it turns it [__] green or some
[__] looks like you put [__] grass
clippings you guys are drinking that
grass clipping things water okay just
drink water just I mean I know I know
water isn't a good grift like it's you
know I'm not really making that much
money of promoting water but uh just
just just drink you some good old
water water it's like the majority of
what your body's made up of is water not
not [__] grass clippings that you
pour into it and then drink it ain't
this going to be embarrassing one day if
like a grass clippings uh drink company
you know what I mean yeah a lawn that
that's what we should call it lawn
clippings AA lawn clippings Aqua
1000 oh my God some of these people they
abase themselves
by by promoting these and you know what
even if we had like boner pills on here
I would totally make fun of them like if
someone came for a sponsorship for the
show and they're like look we want you
to Hawk boner pills I'm like okay but
you don't quite understand how I do
things I'm not going to be like these
are the greatest boner pills of all time
I'm gonna totally make fun of you and
I'm gonna totally make fun of the boner
pills as I'm as I'm telling the audience
about as I'm grifting you know what I
mean maybe we should maybe we should
just come up with some products of our
own like Hunter Biden's boner pills um
lawn law clippings uh La lawn
clippings greens 1000 I'm not making fun
of
anybody I'm not making fun of anybody I
promise oh and I'll never ask you for uh
I'll never ask you for um legal money
for my legal fees and then you use AI to
try to uh lawyer it up in court and then
lie about the AI I'll never do that I'll
never I promise I promise you I swear on
the non Bible that I don't have in front
of me um that I will never ever ever ask
for money for my legal fees and then use
AI to uh I I should say never I
shouldn't say never I shouldn't say
those things I shouldn't say those
things lawn juice Christine says yeah
lawn
juice Jim sh sh Jim you're saying the
quiet party out loud sh
sh
oh my God now they'll never sponsor me
Jim they're never going to sponsor the
show we'll never have lawn juice I swear
to God if ag1 sponsored the show if they
ever did I would totally make fun of it
I would totally be like you know you
could just drink water or you can pour
the lawn juice
in it's up to you I just drink
water good old water without lawn
clippings in it tastes Fant
fantastic tastes
fantastic oh boy all right let's get to
my grift you know what I mean we got to
get to my gri don't we I think so uh if
you want to help support the show
there's several ways you can do it the
most important way you can do it is go
to patreon I'm going to be talking a lot
about the patreon in the months to come
and the years to come because that's
really how the show operates right it's
it's privately funded this microphone is
powered by you and your contribution
and we do so many cool things at the
patreon one of them is every Monday and
Friday if you're in the $20 tier you get
to come and spend an hour with me before
the show in the producers corner on
Discord that's kind of cool Everyone
likes it in the Discord um in the
producers Corner they come every morning
we talk to each other it's not like the
show it's like a big conversation it's
kind of like a like just a conversation
that we're having in a room in a chat
room kind of like a Twitter spaces in
other words that's private amongst us
uh it's really cool we get a lot of good
ideas in there um I I get to hear what
you guys think I get to hear what you
guys are thinking you get to ask
questions sometimes there's all sorts of
great conversations that happen in the
producers Corner that's part of the
patreon the other part of the patreon is
the Sunday rant the Sunday rant is every
single Sunday I do it at 800 PM Central
and we usually go for about an hour
sometimes more just depends on how
[__] angry I am at whatever's going
on or whatever conversation we're having
sometimes we listen to music sometimes
we sing and then we do and then we do
karaoke every once in a while as the
patron and you as a patreon member had
the chance to sign up to come on screen
with me so there's all kinds of great
things and you get a discount you get
discount codes on merch and stuff like
that speaking of merch that's another
way you can help the show is just go to
the Tony michaels.com you go to the Tony
michaels.com and you can go to the top
of the page and you can see here that we
got the the tattoo merch collection um
that's going to happen really soon I am
actually getting this tattoo on January
26th is my appointment um I've already
been in talks uh with the tattoo artist
again we'll have a design hopefully I'll
have a design very very soon and I'm GNA
give an opportunity for people to
contribute for part of the tattoo I'll
probably be announcing that tomorrow
Friday I'll be giving you an opportunity
to contribute for the tattoo and then
you guys are going to get you're going
to get Early Access if you do that
contribution you're going to early
access to the content and then people on
patreon also get early access to that
content um and what it will be is just
videos of me um you know talking about
the tattoo it' be pictures of me getting
the tattoo and we'll be making that
content and putting it out on social
media and on YouTube so you guys get to
see it I think it's going to be really
important especially the first two
phases of the tattoo um I'm really
excited about it and I'm excited that
you guys are excited about it and I I
want you guys to have a piece of it I I
want because it's not just my tattoo um
I I I believe that the reason why I'm
getting the tattoo and the tattoo the
tattoo merch design is going to be an
inspiration for the tattoo that's going
on my arm so not only if you buy the
merch uh will you have a piece of the
tattoo but if you contribute then you'll
get a piece of of the credit for the
tattoo as well so I'll be announcing
that tomorrow but just go to the Tony
michaels.com keep watching there if you
like to buy shots you can buy shots I
know a lot of people like to buy shots
for me and I want to thank everyone
who's bought shots or contributed to the
swear jar and then if you want to get on
screen with your chat you go to vinmo if
you want to do like a super chat I'm not
monetized on um on YouTube because I
guess because of the [__] I say and how
I say it they don't like me they don't
like me so um but they they let me uh
broadcast here so I can do the work
around and be like hey if you want to
get up on screen to a super chat you can
just go to venmo you just click that
link on neony michaels.com that'll take
you there and I'll watch it today if you
want to if you want to do one of those
otherwise go to the patreon it's free to
follow I appreciate if you become a
member it helps me keep the the lights
on it is my job every single weekday to
sit here and entertain you and tell you
the news and yell and scream and push
the narrative so it Cas Gates out into
the country so that we have strategic
outrage so we can engage in our
democracy and the pro democracy
Coalition can save it for us also I
don't want to forget this is great merch
to Everyone likes this even my cat hates
Ted Cruz and even my dog hates Ted Cruz
Merch this is on the Tony michaels.com
as well under the merch stores you guys
can go grab this your hoodies your
t-shirts your coffee mugs all you pet
owners out there and I know you and your
pets hate te Cruz because who doesn't
hate te Cruz who doesn't [__] hate te
Cruz all right let's go to this Jazz I
can't wait to show you this Jasmine
kocet thing oh my God oh my God oh my oh
my God oh my god um I love her so much
here's one of here's one of the clips
from Jasmine Crockett let's roll it
juries are comprised of American
citizens and the people that have
entered pleas of guilty that will be
flipping on your leader in a minute they
are Republicans I do want to point that
out and half of them were Republicans
that were handpicked by Donald Trump
himself so to be clear whatever happens
to your little leader it's going to be
because of that actions that he took so
you can talk all you want to about how
January 6 was nonsense but all of y'all
were running at that time y'all were
grabbing y'all's gas mask and y'all were
running to your offices because you
didn't know if they were coming to kill
you you should have cared that somebody
was there to protect you but instead you
want to play games because you found out
that it was your leader that decided
that he wanted to propagate an
Insurrection on our country so don't
tell me that you care about the
Constitution cuz you don't all you care
about is is Trump getting reelected and
I'll yield the last of my time to my
leader thank you very much Miss Crockett
for your eloquent and powerful and
irrefutable
remarks God all right I think we're just
gonna end the show [__] it I'm I can't
even I can't even follow that that's
that's something I can't follow oh my
God oh my now normally normally I would
hold on to that and let you guys sit
here and suffer but I can't I couldn't
do it I got to we'll watch it a couple
times
today your little
leader you're little leader oh my
[__]
god oh my god oh man I don't know maybe
I should take a break and go rub one off
that was [__] fantastic I'm telling
you that was [__]
fantastic I don't listen I'm usually not
speechless you know this I can talk for
hours and hours and hours and hours and
hours about politics about the daily
news about one [__] thing one I could
take one morsel one little bitty crumb
of what the hell's going on and I can
talk to you about it for two three four
five hours
right but I almost cannot find any
words better than what Miss Jasmine
Crockett did
there but then I would be ignoring all
the other [__] Great
Clips because there's so many more Great
Clips here is here's how the news
started this morning uh with this this
was right before the hearing started and
this is in the hallway outside the
Committee hearing watch who walks down
the
hallway everybody left right left or
right left or
[Music]
righty
today you plan on testifying today
anything you want to anything you want
to say to the
committee
Hunter Biden's hog is in the house folks
that's right Hunter Biden walked in the
room he went into the room um
to uh show all the
Republicans live and in person his his
dingdong I didn't get it out I mean
Marjorie Taylor green wanted to show
pictures of it I'm not kidding you she's
like I want to show pictur piur of his
dick I want to show I want to show
everyone in this room what his dick
looks like because I'm obsessed with it
so much so that I have to enter in
pictures of his [__] into this committee
because that's what it is a [__]
committee get his
hog all over the
television and at one point they're like
in this porn in this porn can we show
porn in the Committee hearing is this
porn and she's like this is not
pornography and Jamie Raskin is like um
I don't think you're an expert um but
you know let me let me uh let me show
let's see if we can find that there
there is a
uh there is a there is and then there's
another committee going on there's
another [__] committee going on with Jim
Jordan now it's not as eventful because
Hunter Biden didn't actually show up in
in that hearing um here is actually uh
Nancy mace you know Nancy mace and there
was another great moment oh my God it's
just it's just a waterfall this morning
of of great things that happened in this
Committee hearing one of the Great
Moments in this Committee hearing is
representative Bert [__] burit berit you
know what I'm talking
about he has to yield his time to Nancy
mace now representative berit [__]
hates Nancy mace and the reason why is
because Nancy mace voted against keeping
Kevin McCarthy as speaker and Bert [__]
wanted to keep Kevin mcarthy he worked
really hard he threatened Matt
gats you remember this do you remember
this oh my god let's rewind let's rewind
I want to tell you this story rewind all
the way back to the beginning of last
year when Kevin McCarthy was trying to
be speaker and they voted Time After
Time After Time After Time and Lauren
bobert and Matt G we're not voting for
him [__] him we're not voting for him
which is their right they got it right
they they're duly elected members of
Congress they get the right not to vote
for him but representative burett leans
in to Matt gats right he's like hey you
know what we got all that dirt on you
because you're a pedo you know what I'm
talking about because you were showing
all those videos and those pictures on
the house floor to me and every I mean
we liked them we like those underage we
like that child porn that you were
showing us on the house floor Mr gats
but you were showing us and we know you
were showing and boy if you don't if you
don't go make a deal with Kevin McCarthy
right
now we're going to make sure to out you
I mean that's what I imagine he said I
mean you couldn't hear there was no
microphones on him but if I had to guess
if I had to guess based on the evidence
that's out there and that what people
have said about Matt gats and how he
conducted himself on the house floor if
I had to guess that's what I would say
representative birdshit said into Matt
G's ear and then Matt gats went and made
the deal remember that he went and made
the he ran to Kevin McCarthy he's like
hey man let's make a deal Let's Make a
Deal Let's Make a Deal and then they
made a deal and Kevin McCarthy became
the speaker and then Matt gats was the
one who retracted that deal and called a
motion to vacate the chair because Kevin
McCarthy kept the government open when
the king king MAA and their dictator in
fear herd the dictator Donald Trump
himself didn't want the Govern kept open
he wanted the government shut down
because he thought it would hurt the
economy and then he could blame it on
Biden if it the economy and he's there
they're going to do it again they're
going to do it again but you remember
that birt
[__] he wanted Kevin McCarthy so much so
that he threatened Matt Gat and then
Nancy mace voted against
him this morning he had he had to yield
his time because he's a little baby back
[__] okay Senator burit talks big talk
and all that [__] but the chairman comr
pile made him yield his time to Nancy
mace and he even showed his contempt for
the yielding being forced to yield his
time to Nancy mace by saying well Nancy
mace I'll yield to her because she just
wants more more moments on Fox
News dude the the Civil War inside the
Republican party is real and it's
palpable and half of them are fighting
over not who's going to be the deer
leader they all know it's going to be
Donald Trump they just want to know who
gets to put the Cheeto dust knee pads on
and give him felatio the most like
that's all they care about they don't
give a [__] they don't give a [__] if
someone else is the leader they want him
to be the leader they just want to give
him fellatio as much as possible because
they know the benefits of giving him
fellatio you know what it
is
oh someone's mentioning um my shows on
Spotify yeah I'm behind on the shows on
Spotify and apple I've had memory
problems here moving stuff around so
it's um I'm I'm getting that fixed I
promise I promise I'm getting that fixed
and we're going to post all those
episodes I think there's three of them
that are not there but we will get them
on we will get them on Spotify and apple
and all the directories soon I promise
I'll get caught up it's just I have
listen
these computers are only so [__] big
and the memory is only so much speaking
of memory only so much here's here's
comr pile being really sad that Hunter
Biden's in the room let's watch Mr
chairman uh chairman comr um first of
all my first question is who brought
Hunter Biden to be here today that's my
first question um second question you
are the epitome of white privilege
coming into the oversight committee
spitting in our face IGN ignoring a
congressional subpoena to be deposed
what are you afraid of you have no balls
to come up here and Mr chairman point of
inquiry Mr chairman
umn if the G if the G lady wants to hear
from Hunter Biden we can hear from him
right now mrman let's take a vote and
hear from Hunter Biden what are
you hold on
order speak in here or no are women
allowed to speak in here or no you keep
interrupting me I'll interrupt the chair
inter a
lady I think that bid should be arrested
right here right now and go straight to
jail our
nation yeah rested right here right now
right here right now right here I
actually you know what I couldn't agree
with her more I I couldn't I couldn't
agree with her more I couldn't agree
with Nancy ma Moore do it do it
[__] do it put him in an gson
take in to jail what what the [__] do
you think Hunter by is scared of the
guy's under Federal indictment in
California he's probably going to comp
some more charges in other states
because Donald Trump appointed a u us
attorney in Delaware to attack him and
to weaponize the Department of Justice
against Senator Biden because Donald
Trump knew that Joe Biden would beat him
that was the whole purpose of the
[__] laptop talk in the first place
and the laptop lie in the first place
that's why they went to Ukraine to try
to get to try to get the Ukrainian
president to [__] prosecute Joe Biden
and Hunter Biden and Ukraine or at least
say they were investigating him when
they weren't because there wasn't an
investigation to have because there's no
evidence of
Investigation it's the reason why they
look like fools this morning and we
should encourage more of it we should
encourage more of it that's why I want
yeah [__] yeah arrest Hunter Biden put
him in handcuffs in front of the entire
[__] world for contempt after he
showed up in your room where you can
talk to him directly I I Nancy mace you
[__]
clown what a bunch of
[__] what a bunch of [__]
horeshit these people are selling and
you think the American people are going
to buy this [__] give me a [__] break
the story coming out of today is that
Republicans are really upset that Hunter
Biden showed up to testify so they voted
to hold him in contempt Americans are
going to go what the [__] are you
talking about they don't know about any
of this [__] the only people who know
any of the fake ass evidence anyways is
the [__]
cult hell even people out there who pay
attention to politics don't even know
what the [__] evidence is because
they can't provide it to anyone in any
official hearing they can't show
us and they want they want to have a
[__] private meeting with Hunter
Biden so that the American people can't
see the evidence that they say is
there don't you see how the American
people people are not going to buy this
line of [__] and their entire narrative
is going to [__] topple and the plot
is slipping right through their [__]
fingers because folks there's only two
things that the Republicans are trying
to sell only two things only two that
Joe Biden is just as corrupt as Donald
Trump so make him the king and the
Border that's it that's it what else
what other [__] thing are they
talking about
huh what you [__] provide me the
proof provide me the proof of what any
Republican is talking about besides Joe
Biden is just as corrupt is is Donald
Trump so we should elect Trump to be
president because he had a better
economy even though the stock markets
higher even though unemployment's lower
even though wages are higher inflation
is going the opposite
direction give me a [__]
break it's the dumbest [__] I've ever
heard of in my life and to think and to
think that we can't put our [__]
heads together and build a
narrative around this [__] cuz the
entire reason why they're doing this is
to protect their Theocratic monarchy the
theory of it
really they're
authoritarians they're circling the
wagons for the king because without
their
help without their help to demonize
Hunter
Biden and without their help to convince
the American people that Joe Biden is
just as corrupt there ain't no [__]
way they can get the American people or
people in the Republican primary voters
to believe that Donald Trump should be
president again and give him another
chance to [__] try to [__] and rip up
our
constitution to become dictator for a
day get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense there is no such thing as
dictator for a day not going to
happen and not on our watch not in this
[__] country that's the most
unamerican thing I've ever seen and the
display this morning that Americans are
gonna see
again are that Republicans just want
Hunter Biden to show up so they can
question him about his crimes and he
showed up and they voted to hold him in
contempt their entire narrative where he
stood up you stood outside the C capital
on the Senate side you didn't actually
come in the room he was in the room
today with his attorney ready to [__]
answer
questions he knew they wouldn't he knew
they wouldn't because they don't have
question real questions to ask that the
American people give a [__] about listen
the American people want to know what
the Republican party is going to do
about their earned benefits like Social
Security and Medicare the American
people want to know how you're going to
make sure that they don't go broke
because of a [__] medical bill the
American people want to know what the
Republicans are going to do about
protecting women's rights and making
sure that they have access to [__]
health care and that they have privacy
in their [__] doctor's offices that
they can drive on roads and cross
imaginary lines to go to a doctor's
appointment without facing criminal
prosecution they want to know what
[__] Republicans are going to do to
protect our fellow Americans the LG btq
Community from these [__] neo-nazis
that want to kill them that want to
exterminate
them that's what the American [__]
people want they want a decent [__]
wage they want to make sure their kids
are [__] educated they want to make
sure that their kids can grow up and
live in a better [__] America than
they live
in what the [__] do you think the
American people want to see Hunter
Biden's
dick get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense sense they got a lot better
[__] to do and a lot more [__] to handle
like going and buying groceries and
getting their kids to school trying to
figure out how they're going to pay for
a mortgage or even if they can get a
[__] mortgage anymore because they
can't make a decent [__] wage because
they got to sit and wonder if they're
going to go broke because of a [__]
medical bill they don't know if their
[__] kids are going to go to college
because you can't [__] pay for it
anymore and even if you do pay for it it
takes you entire lifetime to pay that
[__] off to make you feel like you're
part of part of
society that's what the [__] American
people
want and when they hear the news that
Republicans the only thing they're
talking about is shutting down the
government making sure that brown people
don't come here and Hunter Biden's dick
you think they're going to vote for that
[__] get the [__] out of
here these are not popular policies I
don't give a [__] what a poll says I
don't care what the media says I don't
care what other Talking Heads say I
don't give a [__] what tyt midest touch
I don't give a [__] what any of them say
I don't give a [__] I'm G to tell you
the [__] truth the way I see it the
way it
is the American people don't give a
[__] [__] about what the [__] you're
talking
about
and it's time we all get on the same
[__] page and [__] dunk
these goddamn fascists in the [__]
trash once and for
all [__] them we do not we do not have
to sit around and argue what's in the
14th Amendment section three to beat
these [__]
dummies we don't have to sit and argue
about who's going to be on the ballot
who's not go [__] vote
that's where your energy should be
that's where your passion should be for
the battle at The Ballot Box not in some
[__] courtroom trying to take some
[__] off a ballot that isn't going to
happen
anyways CL whining and complaining about
how a [__] trial ain't going to
happen when you want it to happen when
you could be using your [__] energy
to get your ass out there and [__]
engage in your
democracy that's what this is
about yes we have to properly mock them
yes we have to make fun of them we have
to show them for the clowns that they
are we have to convince the American
people that these people don't give a
[__] about you they've never gave a [__]
about you they only care about one
[__] thing and that's Donald Trump
right here right now right here right
now and it's time right here right now
that we do this
[__]
yeah I know I know a lot of Tony you you
attack the left I'm not attacking the
left I'm attacking their ability to
[__]
message and the energy and the [__]
time and your [__] money that they
Griff from you to put into that
messaging yeah that's right I said
it remember a day when there was
political that we go viral
huh remember a day when political pack
money was used to
mock Grandpa Hitler remember the
day that is no more now is the time for
someone to yell and scream every [__]
day and never
stop our messaging is leaking out do you
think think do you think without having
a Tony Michaels Jasmine Crockett could
say half the [__] she just said I'm not
saying I I I made Jasmine Crockett but I
sure as hell give her [__] space to
say that [__] I sure as hell give Joe
Scarboro the space to say the [__] he
says on N
MSNBC that's the whole
point I give space the way I say it and
how I say it when I say it before anyone
else will say it because they ain't got
the [__] nuts to say it because
someone else will tell them you can't
say that we'll take money out of your
[__]
pocket you can't say that because you
might offend this
group you can't say that that way oh man
you can't stand up for what's real and
what's right and what's [__]
reality you'll piss people off on
Twitter Tony I don't give a
[__] this ain't about
Twitter this ain't about [__]
advertisers this ain't about athletic
greens or selling [__] lawn juice are
selling deeds in Scotland are using AI
in a [__] courtroom and then lying
about
it what this is about is our [__]
democracy and forming a message to win
to [__]
win I don't care how much of a [__]
degenerate I am I am I'm a [__]
degenerate I'm not [__] perfect never
have been don't admit to being perfect
either [__] actually I think it's
probably one of my best attributes is
that I'm not [__] perfect so I don't
have to tiptoe around on [__]
eggshells and pretend I'm someone I'm
not changing my position when Twitter
tells me it's the wrong
position you'll never get that [__] from
me no [__]
way
I'm going to lean into this [__] all
[__] year and pass this
year and I know you're going to stick
with me because I know you're just as
pissed off as I
am because you're paying attention but I
want to be
clear I want to be
clear most Americans are not as pissed
off as we are
yet yet is the key
word the only way the only way that we
get the American people as pissed off as
we
are is we [__]
show the American people
[__] that Republicans
are that they're derel and they
Duty they're a
joke it's not even worth the
time to even consider that they would be
a governing
party let alone let alone a majority
party in any government
anywhere their hypocrisy is astounding
and it's on display not just in the
oversight committee but in the Judiciary
Committee today let Eric swell show it
to you Mr chairman is this a
joke no seriously is this hearing a joke
this is a committee that I'm sorry this
is this is this morning yeah it is this
morning go ahead now cares about
subpoena
compliance and we're going to hold
somebody in contempt for subpoena
compliance that's really interesting
because to me it seems like you believe
we all had our memories wiped 608 days
ago when you failed to honor your own
subpoena you see on May 31 20
22 as the January 6 committee was
investigating the greatest crime ever
committed in America with the most
arrests the most convictions a crime
against our Congress our constitution
our democracy all they wanted was for
you and a few of your
colleagues to cooperate to provide any
information you had and what you all
did for 600 in eight
days and counting you didn't show up and
you want us to take this proceeding
seriously where you have an issue with
somebody
else's compliance with a subpoena
somebody who actually is willing to come
forward publicly something you were not
willing to do something you and Mr
McCarthy and others who were asked to
testify were not willing to do so
seriously is this a joke if it's a joke
great this whole Congress has been a
joke so it would be in line and on brand
with what has been taking place but I
have to ask like how dumb do you think
the American people are that you would
seek to hold someone in contempt when
you are
608 days 15 hours 21 minutes and 47
seconds out of compliance of your own
subpoena I don't know Mr chairman if if
it is your practice to look the other
way when crimes are committed but it's
not my practice and it's not my
colleagues practice so what is this
really all about it's about this
chairman speaking Johnson and the magga
majority acting as Insurrection
LLP creating the biggest law firm in
Washington DC to work every single day
in this building on behalf of just one
client the former president Donald Trump
and to carry out his Petty grievances
every single day okay that's great you
won the majority it's your prerogative
but the cost to the American people is
we aren't doing a single thing and this
committee to address gun violence the
mass shootings that occurred in the 3
weeks that we were gone we haven't done
anything to address what's going on at
the border a president who's willing to
negotiate and find ways to better secure
it we're not doing anything to bring
down the cost of Health Care and take on
the pocketbook Financial Breathing Room
issues that the American people care
about okay let's talk about
Hunter Mr cmer and Mr Jord said we want
Hunter Biden to come in Hunter Biden
said okay I will come in Mr comr said
two different times we will take his
testimony publicly or we will take it
privately we will take it publicly or we
will take it privately Hunter Biden said
okay let's do it publicly I don't trust
you all to take it privately because you
haven't released the depositions that
you have taken privately can't blame him
for that he wants to come in and testify
publicly you won't take yes for an
answer and so then you move it to let's
take it privately I think you want to
take it privately because you have
nothing I think you want to take it
privately because you don't want to see
marjerie Taylor green display the
non-consensual nudes from Hunter's
laptop again I think that's why you want
to take it
privately but he comes in anyway you
won't take yes for an answer and let me
just break some news for you Mr chairman
just down the hallway Hunter Biden is
sitting in the oversight committee he's
ready to testify publicly it appears so
let me just challenge you one more time
if you're so eager to take his testimony
publicly I move that we adjourn right
now and take his public testimony and
bring him in here right
now and there you have it there you have
it perfect do you hear it the American
people don't want you to do this [__]
the American people want you to use your
power and your government to represent
them not Donald Trump not Donald Trump
to make some [__] political argument
about Hunter Biden's dick that's not
what we want that's not what the
American people want are voted for you
for or voted you in the slim majority
that you have Hell by the summer we may
have we may have a [__] we may have a
majority and the Democrats may have a
majority and Hakeem Jeff be the goddamn
speaker Andy ogles is under an
investigation just
like just like representative Santos
was that's right he's in big trouble I
want to I want to point out some descent
you know that I appreciate descent here
on the Tony Michaels podcast I welcome
it I welcome descent especially from
people who are likeminded and on my side
because I believe you're on the you're
in the Pro democracy Coalition so I
wanna I wanna I want to um lay out
something very
clear Susan Susan says um Brenda don't
mess with mest touch Tony you're uh
leading the blues they are leading the
blues to win in
2024 why why don't I get to comment on
what I
see why is it that I H that I have to
keep my mouth shut about something huh
is this what we really want is this what
we want we want people to just ignore
certain things because if we ignore
those things you know I've always been
told we do it differently on our side
our side our side our side which
technically I'm the anti-establishment
I'm anti-establishment
how many times do you hear me say the
current president's name how many times
do you hear me on this show talk about
the the current president's
accomplishments I think they speak for
themselves I think the American people
understand those
accomplishments I don't think that we
have we we stand around trying to sell
them I think it makes a shill for the
establishment and most of America is not
establishment they're anti-establishment
I don't know and and it doesn't mean
that they're left or right it just means
they don't want to be told what to do or
who to vote
for they want to vote against something
it's very
important Fred says their their reach is
Way Beyond Tony's I think you're talking
about minus touch here Fred now I don't
think you're dissenting I think you're
just stating facts here that their reach
is much further than mine I mean I guess
that's true do have way more followers
and they have way more people who give
them money if that's what you mean I
think that's what you mean uh Brenda
followed up and said it was through them
that I started watching Tony very
disappointed right now you are welcome
to be disappointed you're welcome to be
disappointed again you're welcome to be
disappointed in my views on the 14th
section three you're welcome to be
disappointed about my views on the March
4 trial that is not going to
happen you're more than welcome to
be um upset at me about cameras in
courtrooms let's see what else I don't
know there's so many things so many
things that I'm right about because I
just don't I don't try to [__] shill
to Twitter or the the crowd on Twitter
the Pitchfork mob on Twitter that's not
what I'm here to do I'm not here to be
popular it's not what I'm trying to do
it's a little different and I get to
point out my job I my job is to point it
out whenever I see it uh Cole says here
um he saysi miss Gabe on the show just
watching clips and laughing at them too
much preaching lately I mean I I I agree
with you I I wish I wish we could just
sit and laugh about Clips all day long I
mean it'd be really that would be a hell
of a time like it would be great if we
could get back to that thing where we
could just laugh and Chuck it up but
what we got to do is we got to get
serious about this stuff these people
are [__] serious they are not joking
they are not kidding around let me let
me show you an an example I was I told
you I'd show you an example here it is
being indicted for you um my first
thought went to well Jesus Christ died
for my sins Jesus died for me and so I
it connects in my brain that way like
okay he's doing this for us as a country
to make the changes we need to make and
he's the target where we don't have to
be he's Jesus he's
Jesus I I i' I've been telling you the
threat the threat is is the disease of
white Christian
nationalism I showed you yesterday the
difference between God made a farmer and
that the plagiarized prop Nazi
propaganda God made Trump I showed you
those two pieces of propaganda okay I
showed them both yesterday almost in
their entire
I think I showed God I think I showed
God made a farmer or so God made a
farmer which is the the speech that Paul
Harvey gave in the late 70s to the FFA
convention to a bunch of high
schoolers um I believe I played that one
in this entire I don't think I played
all of the Trump one yesterday but we
played it the other day but they're both
they're both Christian
nationalism that's right so God made a
farmer and God made Trump are both
Christian nationalism they're playing to
Christian nationalism just be a good
Christian and be a good American and be
a
farmer just be a good Christian be a
good American and vote for Trump because
God made farmers and God made Trump now
Trump is bastardizing so God made a
farmer because it's not inherently
racist it's not inherently fascist okay
so God made a farmer is Christian
nationalism that piece of propaganda is
to plate to someone's Christian
nationalism to get them to stay in rural
areas to continue to be Farmers so they
don't go out into the world and discover
well there's a hell of a lot more in the
world than that [__] [__] box Farm
I'm on it's propaganda Christian
nationalist
propaganda that the late great Paul
Harvey gave it a speech at the FFA
convention I think I believe if my
memory serves me right is 1978 is what
we found out
yesterday God made Trump is white
Christian
nationalist propaganda it's a little
different it's a little more fasy if you
want to say that it's got this um Hitler
taste to it where he's a deity he's a
king and do your white Christian
nationalist Duty and vote for him put
him to be the
dictator and what would make you believe
believe that let's hear it again being
indicted for you um my first thought
went to well Jesus Christ died for my
sins Jesus died for me and so I it
connects in my brain that way like okay
he's doing this for us as a country to
make the changes we need to make and
he's the target folks Trump is not is
not the [__]
problem it is this this is the
disease it's white Christian nationalism
someone someone tweeted at me this
morning they're like white Christian
nationalism that doesn't
exist like
what what white Christian nationalism
doesn't exist what the [__] are you
talking about I called this white
Christian National I guess because they
saw a black man standing there I'm
assuming it's her husband or her
boyfriend or I I don't know a friend I'm
not really sure who this guy is but I
guess because of black guy standing
there
that doesn't make it even if she was
black this is still white Christian
nationalism you understand that and it's
the threat it is the [__] threat it
connects in my brain that way all right
let me show you where a lot of this [__]
comes from listen to this you've seen
this guy Nick FES right now he's on a
show here and this show is um it's
called America first Christmas money
bomb and he's he's on with a a white
Christian nationalist Vincent James I
played him on the show a time or two
before but he doesn't show up on camera
here but listen to their back and forth
here it's going to gross you out but I'm
telling you the lady that you just saw
that said hey I'm putting Jesus and
Trump in my mind this is how I'm
connecting the two things all that
messaging Cascades out from this
[__] this [__] Nazi this is
the Nazi that paled around with Kanye
West the guy who said I love Adolf
Hitler Adolf Hitler did a ton of great
things and they went and they had dinner
with Trump you remember this is the guy
this is the [__] Nazi that went and
had dinner with [__] Trump and I've
been pointing him out for years years
I've been showing Nick fluentes on this
show because his messaging Cascades out
like my messaging Cascades out he
doesn't need a huge audience he doesn't
need a huge following he doesn't need to
grift hundreds of thousands of people
into buying lawn juice or deeds to
Scotland or give to a legal fund that's
used for AI he doesn't need to do that I
mean he does do that he is a grifter I'm
not gonna lie he he is a grifter because
he's lying to people maybe he believes
it I mean if you actually believe
something if you believe a lie does it
make it a lie it's kind of like if a
tree falls in the woods and no one's
around to hear it does it make a sound I
don't know I mean you'd have to go there
to find out but then someone would be
around right it's kind of like shroy
dingers Nazi right here you know what I
mean all right let's listen to Nick
Fuentes the fact that we have sort of
paved the way right and and and made it
easier for people to to to talk about
these things I get what you're saying
you're kind of like jealous like it's
it's like what the [__] man it's like
dude I had to like I lost my job I you
know all these things happened to me and
lost my bank account and you know
whatever and you know to say these
things it's kind of like uh almost like
you know Martin Luther King in a way
kind of or Ros par [__] God yeah
where were the first ones we're the ones
getting beaten down and like fire hosed
and [__] like yeah oh my [__] God can
you imagine can you imagine if I was
like oh man oh man you you say bad
things about me in the chat that that
makes me Martin Luther King and Rosa
Parks because you comment on me and I
lost my bank account because I'm a
[__] Nazi
what listen I'm a felon okay and I I
have Federal Federal convictions and I
had Banks tell me I can't have an
account have I ever once been like oh
man oh poor me poor me because I can't
they oh man because of something I
did what a bunch of [__] [__] this
is the whole thing that I hate about
these [__] absolute Free Speech
[__] these people don't believe
in free speech they're sitting there
saying because we were the first ones
out there saying because they're the
ones saying the white Christian
nationalist stuff they're the Nazis
they're the ones pushing the messaging
right they're the ones pushing the
narrative that's what they're doing uh
someone's asking if I Can Vote Yes I can
vote in the state of Missouri as long as
you served your time and you're past
your your past your sentence you can get
your right to vote back in a lot of
States you can some states you can't I
actually think people should be able to
vote in prison maybe it's because I'm
biased because I once was but I'm
telling you it's a thing that we should
consider it's a really and we should
consider people who aren't who aren't
American citizens to vote in their local
communities as well because they are
part of those communities whether you
like it or not they own property they
own businesses their children go to the
schools and they're not allowed to vote
for the people run the schools get the
[__] out of here that doesn't make any
kind of sense whatsoever in a democratic
constitutional republic it just doesn't
make sense but let's get back to this
nonsense of not making sense these two
chuckleheads are comparing themselves to
M MLK Jr and Rosa Parks because they
said something and lost something
because they said
it no
no you said something and you're facing
the
consequences you're facing the
consequences is what you're
doing just like everyone who says
something faces the consequences hell I
showed you some comments here earlier
here look look um here's a consequence
let me find it
back
uh here it is here's a consequence of my
speech this morning Brenda says and
Brenda I appreciate you on Facebook I
appreciate you coming and commenting I
appreciate you watching I appreciate you
having passion for this issue it was it
it was through them that I started
watching Tony very disappointed right
now that's a consequence of what I said
that's a consequence right I might there
might be more consequences hell I think
there's several hundred consequences in
the last few weeks because I'm not going
to back down from my principles in the
way that I view it I'm not going to back
down for my position just because some
people don't think it's popular or don't
think I should say it out loud and I'll
suffer the consequences I'll suffer the
consequences just like these boneheads
need to suffer the consequences of their
speech yeah it's kind of like that it's
almost exactly like how oh yeah blacks
were hit with fire
hoses digital fire hose digital fire
hose they believe that they're hit with
a digital fire hose oh because they just
they so
oppressed what a bunch of [__] C baby
bigots but again folks they realize in
in in this in this little [__] weird
ass Dia tribe where they compare
themselves to Martin Luther King and
Rosa Parks who they hate with a passion
because Martin Luther King and Rosa Rosa
Parks delivered us part of the civil
rights movement and made civil rights in
this country and the Civil Rights Act
something that we could get past in our
Congress and the president United States
would sign it in that moment in American
history because they were on the front
lines and these [__] these
chuckleheads hate the [__] Civil
Rights Act they hate that black people
have rights in this country they [__]
hate it they would love to go back to
the day of
segregation they would love to go back
to the day where they could tell black
people where they can and can't be and
what counters they can and can't eat at
what bathrooms they can't and can't be
in what water fountains they can and
cannot drink out of sounds [__]
sounds really [__] familiar in this
day and age doesn't it doesn't it
hearken you back to a time when when
when [__] bigots who were in power in
this country are telling people what
they can and cannot
do
huh but that's it's and it's
disgusting but what they're saying about
their messaging and they're saying about
what they were the first to it and they
were the first to spread this
messaging they're right
the
right and it's because we took our Eye
Off the
Ball we took our Eye Off the
Ball we thought we thought we could sell
the American people all kinds of crazy
[__] and just give it a two-word phrase
not explain
it really not give him the reasons
why we can just do that and it would it
would be okay and they would
everything can be all right they're
smart enough we don't need to message
that well we just need to give them the
data right just need to give them the
data and the facts and the
polls and we'll we'll scare them we'll
scare them into supporting what we want
them to support right that's what we'll
do that's what we'll
do but now we're in a now we're in a
state
in our
country where this
morning our elected officials the House
of Representatives is more worried that
Hunter Biden be held in contempt when he
showed up in the room that they're going
to vote him in contempt
for way more worried about
that I mean here listen listen to
[__] Trump's lawyer yesterday
this is crazy [__] listen to
it in fact Joe Biden could be prosecuted
for trying to stop this man from
becoming the next president of the
United
States did you hear what he just said
that Joe Biden can be prosecuted for
stopping Trump from being the president
of the United
States now we know yesterday we heard
heard that Donald Trump and his
attorneys argued in court that they
think that Donald Trump as the President
of United States can order SEAL Team Six
to
murder his political opponents and
assassinate his political opponents and
because he did it as president then he's
immune from any crime he can go and he
can
murder he can order an assassination on
his political opponent and Bam he's
immune [__] murder
immunity but listen to what he says and
really pay attention to it listen in
fact Joe Biden could be prosecuted for
trying to stop this man from becoming
the next president of the United States
what so Joe Biden can be prosecuted
because he tries to run in the
Democratic party because isn't Joe Biden
really I mean isn't Joe Biden when he's
running for president of the United
States against Donald
Trump
isn't isn't he trying to stop Donald
Trump from being the president of the
United
States isn't he he's trying to stop him
from being the king the
authoritarian the authoritarian
Theocratic
Monarch right that they really want that
they so desire the fear
her Grandpa Hitler
they want it so
bad that they could
prosecute Joe
Biden for trying to prevent Donald Trump
I mean that's what Joe Biden's actually
doing right now I actually don't think
Joe Biden wants to run for president
again I don't think he wants to like
it's not in his wheelhouse
desire I actually don't believe that he
he wanted to run in
I mean I don't talk about Joe Biden much
but let's talk about
him I think Joe Biden really wanted to
run in
2016 against Hillary Clinton and and
Bernie Sanders in the primary I actually
think I think Joe Biden probably would
have
won and that complicated mess in 2016 in
the Democratic primary I think Joe Biden
would have stood out between Bernie
Sanders
and and Hillary
Clinton but that wasn't in the cards for
him he had personal issues his son had
just
died it's a tough thing to go
through I can only
imagine when 2020 was
approaching Joe Biden I think he
believed he could beat Donald Trump I
think he knew he beat
him it's why he ran and I think he knew
if he could win the
primary against all the competition that
was
there KLA Harris Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren Pete Buddha Judge
Andrew Yang I'm not saying he was
competition I'm just you know he was
there Tulsi gabard that Russian asset
she was there too not much of
competition but Joe Biden knew if he
could beat those people in the
Democratic primary especially when he
was way behind when he had no money
people counted him out in
Iowa you remember this he was broke his
campaign didn't have any
money then he went to South Carolina he
won
big because he he won in the primary it
was clear it was clear that black people
in this country knew who could beat who
could beat Donald
Trump they knew it
they knew that [__] they knew it could
beat Donald Trump and they
overwhelmingly went to the polls and
voted for Joe Biden and I believe the
same thing probably would have happened
in 2016 to some degree maybe not with
much as much enthusiasm to get rid of
Joe to get rid of Donald Trump with Joe
Biden and I actually think I actually
think that Joe Biden doesn't want to run
again but he absolutely knows he has
to cuz he has to prevent this [__]
fat
slug from becoming the Theocratic
Monarch that he wants to be the dick
taster that he wants to
be dick taster for a I only want to
taste dick just for one day one day I
love the taste of it but just for a day
and then how it
works when you want something so bad in
your
base in the entirety of your voting
Block in your party you back them in a
corner and you force them to do [__]
they don't want to do like talk about
Hunter Biden's
dick and that how it works you just
dictator for a day but a't that what Joe
Biden's
doing is what Joe Biden's doing is
trying to prevent him from become
president listen to it again in fact Joe
Biden could be prosecuted
for trying to stop this man from
becoming the next president of the
United States so he he can be prosecuted
for running against him because what
else is Joe Biden doing because again I
don't I and Biden has said it I'm not
making this [__] up I'm not just [__]
pulling this [__] out of my ass Biden
has basically
said out of his own mouth if Trump
wasn't running I wouldn't [__] run
the only reason why I'm running cuz I
know I can beat the pants off that that
fat
[__] the wrinkly old diaper filled
stench filled pants off that son of a
[__] Biden knows he's gonna beat him
Biden knows how to beat
him it's very
clear and there ain't no Democratic
alternatives to an incumbent president
who has the impeccable record that Joe
Biden has under such slim majorities I
might
add I I I heard I keep hearing this [__]
here let me show you a clip speaking of
and we might as well go on a tangent
here with the with the Biden thing but
I'm gonna talk about him I might as well
talk about I don't talk about him that
often very rarely right and it's usually
not the shill but I like to make fun of
people
so um man godd damn why aren't some of
these clips that xchan is
horrible xchan is such a pile of [__]
anymore I can't even get some of these
clips to play all right I'll just tell
you about
it so in New
Hampshire but Maryanne Williamson you
remember her from the tyt you remember
the whole tyt thing this is the same
thing this is the same thing um when uh
let's
see Fred said earlier Susan their
reaches Beyond Tony so is
tyts so is that TT has way more people
watching than they do me um but you know
that's okay um and I went after them and
people at first were like you shouldn't
say that about them you shouldn't say
that and then they went watch them like
you should say more of that because
they're [__] full of [__] they're
grifters I'm like yeah I told you um and
but here's Chris Webb this morning he
says this is sad the New Hampshire
primary listen two weeks away and long
chat presidential candidate Dean
Phillips had a single worst campaign
event ever no one showed up at his meet
and greet yesterday for his own except
accept his own staffers apparently 7% of
New Hampshire voters who say they're
willing to vote for him had other plans
and this is Dean Phillips showing up and
he's the only one there no well the
press was there to take a video um but
that's it listen if you're believing
polls you're believing nonsense the same
polls that are saying that Dean Phillips
has 7% in New Hampshire let me show you
what those polls are saying um here's
here's on Fox news quoting CNN polls
look at
this right Brian like you said earlier
it's a different story in New Hampshire
if you look at these polls this is the
CNN poll it's a CNN University of New
Hampshire poll it says that Trump is
still in first place 39% but look at
Nikki Bailey oh my God she's really
gaining some look at Nikki Haley oh look
look
32% oh my God amongst Republican primary
voters I don't believe this for a second
this such [__] come on man do you
believe this no I mean I believe that
DeSantis has less than five% and there's
no way rad damama dingdong has 8% and
not only that Chris Christie has worked
his ass off of New Hampshire and he only
has 12 and we're supposed to just
blindly believe these
numbers come on
man come on this ain't real is it and
this is a CNN poll too what's Fox News
doing reporting fake news you know what
I mean I mean I'm just trying to go off
their sentiment but let's listen to
their narrative it's wild stuff Brown
she's now 32% you know what the part of
the reason is uh Trump's got the
Republican support right but when you're
an independent you're an undecided you
can vote in this pick a primary democrat
or republican there's no Democratic
primary so they're all going for
Republicans Haley leads 40 percentage
points to uh Trump leads among
conservatives by 40 37 registered
Republicans 17 people without college
degrees but here's where Haley surges
she's tops Trump by 42 points among
moderates 20 26 points with Undeclared
voters and 12 among college graduates
this okay now now explain how many
Republican voters are primary voters and
how many moderate and independent voters
are primary voters in New Hampshire in
the Republican primary now explain that
okay keep going this is why her numbers
are so strong in the general because
that looks more like the general
election but uh that's because New
Hampshire's a little bit different and I
think in the long run they're got to say
that Governor sinunu had a real positive
effect on this race for Nikki Haley
right and uh regarding Nikki Haley
surging uh yesterday she picked up and
this we're going back to Iowa uh because
it's next up uh Haley picked up an
endorsement of a longtime Iowa GOP donor
and fundraiser a fellow by the name of
Cam Sutton he'd been a fundraiser for
Trump in 2020 he said essentially he's
putting his money and his support behind
Nikki who you know the whole thing about
elections is you want to Surge at the
end she is yeah surge at the
end listen this is more we're in normal
times [__] I keep telling everyone
this I keep saying it and I know you
you're like Tony there's people yeah
they're
just sick of hearing you say the stuff
that's not
popular really want you to say stuff
that's popular I mean not the people
listening still you know we want you to
say stuff that's popular please just say
the stuff that's popular just say Nikki
Haley's gonna win just say Trump's going
to be 14th and he'll be off a b just say
just say that that you think that the
Supreme Court rule in your favor because
if they don't then it'll be banned
and and the trial will definitely start
a much worse because there's no way it
can't start a March Force because Jack
Smith is going to save us and all kinds
of
[__] big St s says Tony showing a bol no
I'm showing how ridiculous it
is I think it's way
off I think the poll is way off way off
and really honestly if it isn't off okay
let's postul let's postulate here let's
say this poll that they put up on the
screen here let me bring it back up a
[__] Twitter God damn it hang on a
second let me bring this poll back up
give me just a second bring this poll
back up on the screen here and let's
postulate rather um Nikki Haley wins or
loses um based on this thing okay so
let's let's say they're correct in their
commentary and saying that this primary
is going to reflect the American vote
which it's not there a bunch of hogwash
that's a bunch of [__] to believe
that the New Hampshire primary is going
to appear to be the general election
vote it's a bunch of [__] [__] okay
that's [__] nonsense that's nonsense
the Democratic or the Republican New
Hampshire primary has never reflected
the American
electorate Now by them saying oh well
people it's an Open Primary so they can
pull the ballot and there's no
Democratic primary so blah blah blah
yakity SCH smacky
right okay but not only that we are not
in normal times and we're not in normal
polling times either
we are well past the days where polls
are even close to being correct they're
not they're [__] [__] they have
not been right in the last three Cycles
last three it's not like oh well this
one they were wrong this one they were
kind of right and this one they're wrong
they're wrong [__] I was even wrong in
the last election yes I said it I was
wrong in the
2023 year
election I was wrong about Kentucky I
really thought the Democratic and coming
governor was going to lose and he didn't
and he didn't I was pretty sure about
Virginia I was damn sure about Ohio and
the reason why I was damn sure about
Ohio is because it was a measure about
the Constitution and taking away
people's [__]
rights and I was pretty goddamn sure
about Virginia too when the governor
Glenn yunan went around the state and
said just elect Republicans and I'll
take your rights away from you
listen folks Americans don't like that
[__] and Nikki Haley has been out there
saying she wants to take your [__]
Medicare your Social
Security she wants to take your earn
[__] benefits R from me she wants to
raise the retirement age on American the
American people she wants to make sure
that there's a federal abortion ban she
wants to make sure to ban Women's Health
Care federally so you can't go from one
state to another she wants to she'll
criminalize it too she'll go down that
road these are not [__] moderate
views these are not the views of
America give me a [__] break the only
one of these [__] up here
talking about not having a federal ban
is Chris Christie and the reason why is
because Chris Christie has some
political Savvy about him he's not a
cultist he was always a Lackey for Trump
but he was is never a
cultist right and he doesn't give a [__]
about it whether Trump's tied to his
political future or not Nikki Haley rad
damama dingdong especially and Ronda
santz give a [__] if Trump is tied to
their political
future so I show this poll to show you
that it's a bunch of [__] but let's
say it's correct let's say the
commentary from Fox News and Ducey and
the other idiot is correct that it
reflects the American people then if
Nikki Haley can win the primary in New
Hampshire then she can win the general
election that's a bunch of [__]
nonsense not even close because when
Nikki Haley gets out there and she's
talking about a a federal ban on Women's
Health Care criminalizing women's
healthare talking about [__] taking
away people's Medicare and Social
Security their earned benefits that they
work their entire lives for their
retirement it's their
retirement she ain't going to
win listen the American people
fundamentally do not want to be told
what the [__] they can and cannot
do and they do not want the government
taking away their [__] that they
earned they're not going to do it why do
you think the [__] Rich push so hard
and work so hard to make sure their
taxes are
lowered it's an American ideal how do
you think they've convinced so many
[__] people out there that just oh
you'll be rich one day don't you want
your taxes lower when you're rich one of
these days come
on but yes they're going to try to take
your Social Security and your Medicare
doesn't matter which one of them it is
whether it's the santis or it's Trump or
it's Nikki Haley but it ain't gonna be
it ain't gonna
be I mean granted they'll all take away
your [__] your your earned benefits
but listen to Grandpa Hitler here on
earned benefits from the very beginning
of this movement I've made a promise to
American seniors I will always protect
Medicare and Social Security as
president that's exactly what I will do
and that's what I did when I was
President of the United States I
protected it Ronda sanctimonious and
Nikki haly on the other hand oh my God I
thought he was actually like when I
first started watching this I'm like
hey he actually is doing normal things
like an actual normal thing he's not
just saying weird crazy
[__] right he's trying to be normal and
then he's like Ronda San demonius I'm
like I'm like no no [__] Ru it
[__] lost me on the whole serious
thing what the [__] okay keep keep going
man and both want to gut Social Security
and Medicare they want to take it away
from our great seniors the Sancus voted
three times to raise the retirement age
to 70 a lot of people don't know that he
a lot of people don't know that a lot of
people don't know that about poop ma Ron
poop ma Ron he hates Medicare hates
Social Security it's because it's a
republican idea that's what Republicans
do see when you vote in Republicans
Republicans want to take away your
earned benefits because what they want
to do is they want to pass on that
savings that we don't give people their
actual money that they earned and we
give it to our Rich donors as tax cuts
it's a thing that we do it's part of our
it's part of our policy points it's
really it's really the only policy that
we have besides I don't know that I
should be king what okay keep going this
is weird he wanted to gut Social
Security he wanted to raise the
retirement age to 70 that's a big
increase and Nikki Haley says the
retirement age at 65 is way too low she
wanted to go above 70 she said she wants
to raise the age to Quote Match life
expectancy which means 73 to 79 years
old that's a big raise that's a that's
that's a big even I even I am older than
that okay I'm an old man I [__] my pants
on The Daily I have to constantly have
my diapers changed and let me tell you
that's not nice it smells Trump smells
it stinks it's disgusting it really is
and let me tell you something you don't
want to wait until you're as old as me
to [__] your diaper and receive your
social security it's something that you
won't want to do
do like the the entirety of Republicans
even the old Republicans you remember a
guy named Paul Ryan you remember that
[__] that [__] was
trying to take our [__] Social
Security our Medicare earned benefits
away from us for [__] years years and
then he became the speaker of the house
and then he bowed down to this guy and
lost his entire [__] career because
he because he sold out to the cult
because he thought oh yeah I would just
get the cult to vote in some [__]
bonehead and this [__] bonehead will
give me a wet pen to take away people's
[__] earned benefits in this country
get the [__] out of here
man [__] out of here with this [__]
this nonsense this is the guy who
cheered cheered on the White House lawn
with Paul Ryan the same guy that wants
to take away earn benefits taking away
people's Health Care in this country
yeah W yeah we did it we took away their
[__] Health Care [__] those
[__] it's basically what they
did and it was all stopped by one
[__] John
McCain John McCain voted down the
destruction of the
ACA pissed Mitch McConnell off [__] this
guy made fun of John McCain because he
couldn't raise his arm because he was a
p and had his arms broken by our enemies
when he was a prisoner of war when he
fought and served his country instead of
having [__] bone spurs yeah
right you want to learn how to attack
these [__]
here's how you do it keep going there
Grandpa Hitler if Nikki Haley got away
most seniors would work their entire
lives right up until the end and then
not live long enough to receive the
benefits they earned and paid for Hy
also as you know supported Rino Paul
Ryan's 2011 plan to gut Medicare that
was the very same plan that led to a
Democrat television ad showing
Republicans willing or granny right off
the cliff destroying Republican chances
in the 2012 election it was a oh man I
love it I love how I love how he he gets
to attack Paul Ryan now and people get
to believe that [__] because Paul Ryan
is against him right do you remember me
saying hey we should not we should not
make these [__] our
friends we we should not make these
[__] our friends we shouldn't
do that
we shouldn't do that we shouldn't make
them our friends because they're not
especially in our narrative when they
grab a hold of it disaster and Paul Ryan
was a disaster it was something that
nobody can believe and supporting Ronda
santis and Nikki Haley or anyone like
that is not going to happen because
they're completely unelectable to
nominate them after their support for
gutting Medicare and Social Security
would be to kiss the election goodbye
now one other thing I'm the one that's
leading Biden by a lot in all of the
elections as you know in 2016 I beat
Hillary Clinton in 2020 we did even much
better got many millions more bad things
happen We're not gonna let that happen
again but we beat him then oh my god oh
man that's [__] rich and then oh I
won in 2016 even though I actually lost
the popular vote but you know that's how
it goes we do that thing it's a thing we
do it's a thing we do it's a thing I got
a vinmo chat here Nicole sent in V
Nicole thank you for the vinmo Super
Chat and Nicole said whoa here there we
go that's better it usually pops me up
over the banner automatically yeah it's
like magic but it the magic didn't
happen there but Nicole you're magical
cuz you sent in a venmo super chat so I
want to bring it up on screen says I
support you Tony I am disappointed in
those disappointed in
you I support Joe for president I don't
believe in corruption in politics I also
don't want the orange fat fascist as
president I'm with you Nicole I'm with
you Nicole I'm with you on it I'm with
you and we're here to stop Grandpa
Hitler from ever thinking that he would
ever win the presidency ever again
listen listen I'm going to prosecute Joe
Biden for trying well listen listen now
I'm gonna prosecute him for trying to
stop me from being the president of the
United States it's a crime to run
against trump it is a crime it is a
crime I don't know if Ronda Sanz Nikki
Haley Chris Christie and R rad damama
dingdong are listening but apparently
you can be criminally charged once
Trump's becomes president because you're
trying to stop him from becoming
president by running against him in the
primary you know you're stopping the
king king Trump all right speaking of I
I got to show you some clips here I I
know this is going to be like off topic
this is going in a different direction
but I love it because they're freaking
out they're still freaking out about
Taylor
Swift oh my God it's so delicious it's
so [__] delicious that they're
freaking out about Taylor Swift and I
wish it was about football so I could
really get off topic but it's not about
football like they're really exposing
why they were mad that Taylor Swift is
having sex with Travis Kelce you
remember this whole thing she showed up
at a foot [__] Chief football game
several [__] months ago and it was
revealed that her and Travis Kelce are
[__] each other yeah it's that's what
they're mad about that Travis kelce's
[__] her and she's [__] Travis
Kelce that's what they're mad about but
all the white fragile toxic male incels
out there they all got really pissed off
really pissed off so much so that they
started spending conspiracy theories
about Taylor Swift not making valid
arguments right like oh her dancing is
not as good as this person or her music
isn't as good as this person or she
shouldn't be popular because of her mu
she's a musician know if they know that
she sings and dances she's an
Entertainer but you know they think
she's a scop I'm not kidding you this
guy is a former FBI agent he came on
Jesse Waters show on Fox News if you
want to call it news if you'd like to
call it that I don't like to call it
that but you know whatever to talk about
Taylor Swift being a scop for the
Pentagon I'm not [__] you listen to
these [__] fragile white men it is
hilarious and
such you know immeasurable amount of
followers she can potentially
single-handedly swing voters because of
just the amount of followers that she
potentially can influence so the answer
is yes Jesse Yeah because when she
posted the link to the vote.org like
hundreds of thousands of young Taylor
Swift fans all of a sudden registered to
vote I wonder who got to her from the
White House or from
wherever from
wherever what she posted a link on her
Instagram
oh my God like you couldn't get honestly
this is so delicious so [__]
delicious they are so mad because there
is no way Jesse Waters could post a link
anywhere on the internet and get more
than maybe maybe maybe a thousand people
to click on that
[__] there is no [__] way that Jesse
Waters could post a L anywhere on the
internet and get more than 1500 people
that's what they're super [__] pissed
off about their little dick energy that
they got Taylor Swift can post a [__]
link to vote.org oh my God vote. can you
imagine can you imagine the Diabolical
thing of getting people registered to
vote can you imagine that oh my God and
I'm sure the Pentagon made sure to have
this
scop of Taylor Swift
posting a link on her Instagram listen
folks she posted a link one time on her
Instagram and they're still talking
about
it they ain't mad because Taylor Swift
sings the songs they don't like that
ain't what they're mad about well let's
see what let's see what they're mad
about who makes that initial handshake
is it the binder
well the admin Administration has what
they consider a perception Optics
management team and those are
professionals that go out and identify
those people who may be unsuspecting
whether with knowledge or without
knowledge to do these type of campaigns
now it is possible that tayor swick
quite frankly does not know that she is
being utilized in a covert manner to
swing vs but the bottom line is that the
Biden Administration is sad
identifying how many followers and how
many voters potentially she can
influence with either right information
or misinformation she certainly can
swing the
voters she posted a link and they went
and registered to vote you stupid [__]
what is to say now what they're scared
of is that she registered a bunch of
women to vote okay that's that's what
they're really terrified of here that's
why it's a scop because if it was like
Charlie Kirk posted on his Instagram
account you remember Charlie Kirk being
really [__] upset and butt hurt that
he could that Taylor Swift could get
more people to register to vote off one
Instagram post than he does talking
three hours of [__]
day I mean I I'll be honest with you I'm
a little jealous right I'm a little I'm
a little [__] I'm a little jealous I
wish I wish I could just post one link
one time and get tens of thousands of
people register to vote wouldn't my
[__] job be easy godamn wouldn't have
to sit here every day talking two hours
a day just [__] send out a post on
Instagram bam it's
done but they act like every single
person that she registered to vote off
that link is gonna vote for Biden right
and they act like that's number one
unamerican and undemocratic and there's
nothing more American than registering
to vote and going to the poll to the
ballot and voting for the person that
you think is best to do the job on the B
regardless of who you're voting for
regardless there's nothing more American
than
that maybe apple pie maybe the movie
where the guy [__] the apple pie I
don't know I think ballots are probably
more
American what had the debate some other
day but what they're really pissed off
about what they're really [__] mad
about is that people respect her opinion
and they value her as a
person not just an artist but they value
her as a person and also she's a woman
with a lot of influence with
women they hate that they [__] hate
that oh my god do they hate women and do
they not want women to vote and they
know that if Taylor Swift puts out a
link and they go and they they
[__] they [__] click on it and
register to vote they're probably going
to vote the way in women's interest of
of women's healthare and not
criminalizing their health care not
Banning their privacy in a doctor's
office you know not making it to where
their lives are in danger because they W
want to have a child and they want to
bring life into this world it's kind of
weird that pro-life people would say
that but you know they're not really
pro-life they're
terrified a
women
powerful
speaking of powerful
women we've only got a few minutes left
and I can't help it I can't help it I
got to do it again and juries are
comprised of American citizens and the
people that have entered pleas of guilty
that will be flipping on your leader in
a minute they are Republicans I do want
to point that out and half of them were
Republicans that were handpicked by
Donald Trumps himself so to be clear
whatever happens to your little leader
it's going to be because of the actions
that he took so you can talk all you
want to about how January 6 was nonsense
but all of y'all were running at that
time y'all were grabbing y'all's gas
mask and y'all were running to your
offices because you didn't know if they
were coming to kill you you should have
careed that somebody was there to
protect you but instead you want to play
games because you found out that it was
your leader that decided that he wanted
to propagate an Insurrection on our
country so don't tell me that you care
about the Constitution cuz you don't all
you care about is Trump getting
reelected and I'll yield the last of my
time to my leader thank you very much
Miss Crockett for your eloquent and
powerful and irrefutable remarks yes and
thank you Jasmine Crockett for making
sure that this show ended on the highest
note it possibly could on the day that
Hunter hog show happened here on January
10th January 10th the Tony Michaels
podcast same time same place tomorrow
whether you love me you love to hate me
surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
in political news no rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow
toning on social media at the Tony
Michaels and until next time raise a
fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
I don't report I don't report sex
crimes Cony for his Indulgence here um
our good friend the gentle lady from
Georgia uh referred to the murder of
Ashley babbit well um the Department of
Justice the United States Attorney and
the US capital police
uh Inspector General all rejected the
idea that there was any point of order
Mr
chairman or
inquiry there's no such thing there's
never been a court hearing Mr chairman
we agreed never charged reclaiming order
here uh
con